ladies gentlemen Hansen are
even though
what's the floor
what's the score well yeah the last time
I looked it was one nil doing it okay
okay but we've had to turn our phones
off and so we can't tell anyone okay but
should anybody be looking please give us
updates important ready already causing
chaos hands I mean as as I said before
we showed that that real it's impossible
to adequately cover a career like yours
in 90 minutes as we're going to attempt
to do so we never to take me a lifetime
yes but inevitably that pick pick some
some highlights out out and what I've
done is I've chosen clips for a number
of reasons
Oh always musically but also perhaps
their significance in the world of the
music and what happened afterwards some
significance to you and also of course
important collaborations and
relationships that you've had in this
business and we've got a lot to get get
through so why don't we dive straight in
we're going to dive straight in with
Rain Man because really Rain Man was the
film that launched you as
internationally it wasn't it where were
you and what were you doing before you
got to Rain Man or when you got Rain Man
all right I did a film called a world
apart and they said it's a great movie
it's actually a wonderful movie which
very few people saw but Diana Levin some
very little since wife saw it and you
know I'm always being very precise about
this story that she went into HMV and
bought him the CD and he was over here
promoting good morning Vietnam and he
didn't have my phone number but he
somebody gave him the address for our
studio down the Lillie Road and 11
o'clock at night there's a knock on the
door I'm opening the door there's a guy
selling their knees
hi my name is Barry Levinson pause I'm a
director I'm thinking yeah you're my mom
both right but I see behind him that
he's - you remember that's all painted
limousines that nobody ever drove so
they were tore those squash down our
little alley
I thought maybe he is um and so so I
should quite recently I asked Barry if
you ever saw a world apart he never saw
the film but he just loved the music and
he sort of said did I want to come to
Hollywood he was actually really worried
that I would say no one to be some sort
of European art snob as opposed to
repeat [ __ ] but it proves doesn't it
you never quite know and you do some
work you never know who's gonna be
listening and who might pick it up yes I
mean that was that was very lucky
because actually just thought before
that just a few months before that Tony
Scott had actually offered me a big
Hollywood movie called
revenge and his producer Missy went and
who you know and and I was crest fall
you know it's like so Barry took a
chance on me but I mean you know I think
Tony and I managed to do a few movies
together after that you know I after
rain man it was okay yeah we'll be
coming to him a little bit later but you
you were struggling a little bit
around this time weren't you you were
trying to get work you're trying to get
money in you had a fat family you'd and
all that kind of thing you know Maggie
made sure I actually left you know this
is a difficult audience let me just
explain to you why you are difficult
audience because I'm not entirely sure
who's in the audience for I know that
nothing in the audience that I can't lie
about anything July that's exactly right
so Maggie made sure you know my children
you know my daughter had shoes and
Roger Greenaway would invite me for
lunch on Sundays
so that I I had one square meal a week
you know so but but but really I mean it
also loft with with you know Maggie
asking this recording engineered this
recording psyllium follow me if he knew
anybody who knew anything about
synthesizers and that's how I you know I
started doing a lot of commercials I was
standing - it was really my mentor so
what was the brief for Rain Man how did
you approach him but actually the brief
was really simple but we I've done that
on a few movies we made a list of what
not to do you know because it's
basically a road movie and road movies
in those days was either drag lis
guitars are sweeping strings so we were
gonna do a jangling guitars or sweeping
strings and I just thought it was
interesting that this character was sort
of so disoriented in the world so that
the music could be just this mashup of
Cuban rhythms with crazy sensors and you
know whatever you know it's it's foreign
foreign was good you know and and I can
get really foreign
well it well let's have a look at the
clip this is when Charlie played by Tom
Cruise is taking Rayman played by Dustin
Hoffman out of the institution that rain
has been in for all this time and
they're going out together on their
first little trip in the in the car
let's have a look at the clip
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a presidential suite dinner's at
6:00 first question has to be did you
pitch that Q so that it was in the right
key for dustin hoffman's humming no I
said the Q to Dustin New York before
yeah yeah I mean the the the the sound
of the bridge is in tune you know
everything you know it's weird side his
crazy head you know I mean one of the
things which might be worth mentioning
is that since I didn't know anybody in
Los Angeles this was all written in
Barry Levinson's office so you know
there was a cutting room and then there
was my room with you know once in from
there and and what kind of sense was
connecting me using what that would be
bragging no sir the Fairlight was very
good right I was like you know big so
but but very loved this idea and I love
this idea that we just be working on
things together and so I mean this scene
is very collaborative obviously you know
and so forth and everything is paged
everything is it's not so much that it's
cut to the music but it's it's it's
obviously the music shape the scene and
the scene shaking the music and did you
have a feeling when you were doing
because I know that when you arrived in
in Hollywood you were a bit shocked by
the the way technology technologically
they were a little bit behind what you
were used to won't be heid you know I
mean I thought Hollywood we all thought
you know we all think Hollywood that
must be it you know they they have all
the technology they have everything and
all that stuff no when I arrived there
it was I mean I'm sorry we were far more
advanced doing things here you know
using synthesizers using electronics the
systems were really not antiquated about
it yeah I suppose it was antiquated but
the idea that you could go and make a
sound on the spot or that you could
write a score and an office as opposed
to the whole idea of us you know you had
to write it on paper you have to give it
to the orchestrator
then the first time the director would
really here it would be with the full
orchestra there and he'd go I don't
really like this and then you know
everybody would go crazy because they
tend the orchestra at home and it would
be a complete rewrite and so everything
was like a compromise and at the same
time a heart attack and this was like
just guys casually working I mean I
remember figuring you know Mark Johnson
who was the producer on this I didn't
really know what a producer did so all
he did was endlessly get us you know
junk from Joe that's the producer feat
he feeds the composer okay it's a very
important living off you know barbeque
ribs forever
but did you have a feeling that this
this was it this was going to be there
no no I mean if you think about this
movie it's it's a strange movie to
become successful you know it's like
there's no car chase in it it's it's
there's no real love story it's it's got
a very ambiguous ending actually it's
got a truthful ending you know because
in this oh there was the other thing
which was the script is really quite
different from how the movie is because
very of course shaped it in his way but
which is you know so I would say well
what about this bit in the script he
goes so so so the script I read was
nothing like the movie and we'll move on
to another film some years later you've
mentioned it already director Tony Scott
the film is Crimson Tide and the reason
I've chosen this is really because this
a lot of people point at this score as
being the beginning of a certain kind of
scoring a certain kind of style that you
have been all attached to very very much
so having kind of invented it and we're
going to look at a scene that that
incorporates that style very much so um
but here you had essentially just come
off winning an Oscar for the Lion King
very different film - Crimson
shall we say I will see a little bit of
Lion King later on um what about this
influence over the future of film
scoring at this moment you presumably
weren't thinking right that's it
I'm gonna change film scoring in this
film what ways no I probably you know
it's interesting you mentioned the
Africa thing so that probably will
describe it the best I want an Oscar for
Lion King i shouldn'ta for an Oscar for
Lion King because Shawshank Redemption
was nominated in the same year and that
is the better score but I won an Oscar
and it was a crazy night hanging out
with Elton and flirting with Claudia
Schiffer in German and nobody could
understand that and being up until 5
o'clock in the morning and then I had a
meeting with Tony Scott and Jerry
Bruckheimer and I played them a cue from
Crimson Tide they said it was absolute
shade and sand so it puts everything
into perspective
during si hey wait wait just just a few
hours ago I was you know like holding
but golden doodle right and in the next
moment it's just like roll up your
sleeves going you know go and do it no I
it wasn't about reinventing film music I
just thought that this was appropriate
for a movie and I remember not coming up
with the idea of the choir because it's
just because I just actually I like the
rock Russians better then
and and I remember Jerry broke out just
being appalled by this idea and us
fighting every day we would come to the
studio and we'd have this argument about
the choirs and after a while I thought
if I was this producer I'd fire my sorry
ass but he actually cared enough to to
hang in there in this conversation
you're turning me wanting to do the coil
and I remember Jerry saying you're not
doing an art movie here and us we knew
that but at the same time we wanted we
just had this ambition we just had these
ideas and what Jerry made me do by
questioning everything is he actually
made me really think it through so
weirdly this you know that you know a
little resistance to the stupid ideas is
sometimes a good thing
since Don Simpson and Jerry Bruckheimer
they they often come in for a lot of
criticism with the kind of thing that
they did and yet their movies show they
really knew what exactly what they would
do stylized and the directors that they
used in order to do what it is that they
wanted what I mean there were more
stories about Don Simpson than almost
anybody yeah but how does he find okay
let me give you one a run story but so
the I thought all right so I didn't get
to do revenge because but Tony hired me
on his next movie which was Jace of
thunder maybe not an you know the
masterpiece we all hoped for but what
was very interesting was Don Don and
Jerry would come and listen to the music
and they would come in and they'd listen
to a piece and there'd be this 20 second
silence and then Don would give this
very articulate criticism or ideas or
whatever just a perfect paragraph and
after a couple of weeks of this ice off
when you know what's with the silence
and he said look I know you spent time
thinking about this piece of music
before you presented it to us so I think
I should have the respect to actually
think about my you know what I'd never
say to you and so whatever you say about
Don he was incredibly creative and he
was very very you know respectful of
the crazy people in the room so let's
set up Crimson Tide thing I mean this is
where this combination of the driving
drum rhythms there percussive strings
and then the big horn lines the almost
became your signature this is where it
was very very long ago yeah 1995 all
right and so just talk me through how
you did then approach approach that film
can you remember all those years ago
well well I mean we're talking about a
writ in the film would you a
relationship between two guys who are
both sides of the tracks as it were well
look the film is really a play it's a
two header you know it's it it pretends
to be an action movie which it
absolutely isn't it's just it's just a
theater play it could be just honest
could be just you and me Tommy I mean so
it really powerful the music had to do
is it had to sort of give you that sense
of of some sort of epicness but at the
same time it had to give you that sense
that above your head was tons and tons
and tons of waters so there's a
suppressive quality about the whole
thing and I just like the agility of
dental where both of the performances
yeah I mean you get you got two of the
greatest actress on the screen so you
don't really want to go and distract
from that too much well this scene is
near the beginning of the film it's
before they had got to loggerheads for
this is a famous scene in the rain when
gene Hackman's character is giving a
speech to his men giing them up for
their mission and and and as usual with
Tori there's like you know sparks like I
mean just watch the way it's lit it's
just beautiful it is it is amazing here
we go
I expect and demand
your very best anything less you
should've joined the airforce
this might be our commander Chiefs Navy
but this is my boat all I ask is that
you keep up with me and if you can't
that strange sensation you'll be feeling
in the city your parents will be my
phone in your ass
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
party a qualification for command
my last breath of polluted air for the
next 65 days gonna miss it they don't
trust Eric can't see
[Music]
it's my favorite part right here right
now
[Music]
Bravo hunter
sir
you knew to shut up and enjoy the view
most eggheads want to talk it away
you're stuck just one up a couple of
points Thanks
I think every composer that sat in that
chair is said that often it's not the
script it's not the way it's shot it's
the performance that can often give them
the inspiration for the music you've got
two awesome performances where you go to
other performances but all that goes
through my mind is Tony and like that
the wide shot of the submarine that's
stoned because we didn't get permission
to film the submarines and so Tony went
out with a helicopter you know and just
grabbed that shot when the SSL bomber
was leaving Harvard how I dialogue no
nobody really knows this is ghosted by a
creditor Tarantino and Alabama becomes a
main character in true romance so you
know and it's Tony it's Tony would
inspire us all all the time by just has
I know he was he certainly was um so
this was really the moment where a lot
of directors and producers started to
say I want my scores to sound like that
I want my scores to sound like and zero
scores drag-and-drop names at the same
time I'm not so one oh by the way what's
the score no no I I was working it son
Franciscan another movie and I got a
phone call somebody said it's Steven
Spielberg on the phone for you just the
way you do right and it was Steven where
I met at this point and he started off
by saying you've ruined my day I'm doing
what works
he said I've listened to Crimson Tide
eight times now in a row and I realized
it's an hour and five minutes long each
time so you know my day is gone all I've
been doing is listening to the score all
day and didn't get any work done so I
think that was a compliment
I think you might be right but wait what
about from you your perspective because
you you've does so many different kinds
of movie there there must be a pressure
often on you from directors to say I'd
quite like you to do that bit that again
in your movie but I know you I know you
want to be creative you want to find new
ways of doing things
directors will say to you I want
something new and executives at the
studio say I want something new and then
you take them by the word and you do
something new and you play to them and
you see that sort of moment of them
going how it's a bit too new and you
realize they're absolutely right you
need to give people a little bit of time
to get used to things and and sometimes
I mean I remember on Sherlock
it was Warner Brothers this big
Christmas movie and it's fiddle spanger
and accordions so maybe that was a bit
you know not quite what they expected
and so there was a little bit of a guy
loved it you know but there was a bit of
a conversation and and I mean the way I
solve these conversations is actually
very simple because sitting in a room
you know just like with bond for
executives or director and composer and
producer is not really an optimum
viewing experience
so the because music is indefensible I
can't actually say to you I can't
explain to you why you should like this
piece of music and either resonates with
you or a thousand but the circumstances
are important so what I do is if there's
a question about anything I say let's
put it in front of an audience I mean I
don't remember too many occasions where
you know that's odd but I mean Sherlock
is a good good example where we've
previewed it in Phoenix Arizona so
that's actually a relatively short
flight from LA but a really long flight
when there's a guy sitting across from
you saying you're ruining the movie
you're ruining it for everybody
and we get to the screening or in the
screening and I'm sitting next to a
woman I have no idea who she is
audience member and we get to the most
contentious bit and she turns to me and
she goes that's genius I'm great tell
him but you know and our numbers were
high on the flight back I couldn't help
going so I'll change it no no don't
touch it yeah but because I know it's a
different experience if you have a
roomful of people but presumably also of
course we are pretending you're not here
it's just Tommy nice um
but presumably with your use of
technology for me from even very early
days for you is a little bit easier in a
sense to demonstrate before demos
necessarily became a word to to them
what it might sound like as opposed to a
composer that was only writing on on
paper then playing it on the piano no
opposite well I'm I'm I'm a terrible
piano player I'm not John Williams I
mean I you know I did get to know Steven
Spielberg a little bit beyond that and
of course I used every opportunity just
go so how does it work with John how do
you guys work in our life because you
want to know you want to know how the
master works and yes John is an
extraordinary competent pianist on top
of being a genius but it is you know and
this is where the French hands come into
it
and then so the first time you really
have a proper conversation it was the
orchestra in the room and I always
thought we have all this great
technology why don't we use it to at
least show where the French holes come
in even though if they sound like shitty
samples or whatever you know eventually
something will happen that will I mean
you can have a collaborative
conversation you know beyond so I treat
the orchestra very differently I don't
treat the orchestra as that thing where
the director here isn't for the first
and it all falls apart because it all
falls apart I don't make changes once
the orchestra's up on the stage it's
entirely about getting a performance out
of them
you know and it is about and I'm pretty
good at programming synth and I can I
can make a pretty convincing noise and
so I love understatement no no no no but
but I love throwing out the challenge to
the orchestra going okay guys I have a
listen to this this is just me so now
bring your passion
bring your emotion and and do that thing
you know do that thing that you do
because orchestras are an expensive
hobby and I've said it a thousand times
but I'm gonna just say it one more time
whatever you say about the film business
or Hollywood the dastardly nature of it
you know everything is true but it
Commission's orchestral music on a daily
basis and that's important on so many
levels because if we lose the orchestra
it's not just we lose the history of our
humanity I think we actually lose a
chunk of our humanity absolutely right
um let's move all the way from Tony
Scott to his brother really talking
about collaborations there was Thurman
Louise but I've had a little quote from
that Ridley said about you that in my
head I listen to houses music and I
don't even have to shut my eyes I can
see the pictures he responds to pictures
now we're moving towards Gladiator to
talk about gladiator how did the
relationship work let's say the
difference between working with Tony's
got and with Ridley Scott well the
difference is that with Tony it was
literally just the most fabulous
creative chaos I mean okay so here
here's the difference Tony would say to
me if you haven't ridden on a motorbike
through the desert at night I'm great I
don't ride motorbikes because you've got
a cow along that would be his way of
explaining something the Billy would
phone meet nine o'clock in the morning
because he knows I'm
he'd go hey do you want do a gladiator
movie and I'd start laughing and go what
men in skirts he'd go no it's not that
self a gladiator movie and the pictures
thing is very important because I I
learned actually on gladiator never -
don't read the script don't read the
script on a ready Scott film go to
dinner swiftly and get him to tell you
the story because then you figure out
what what support for him and because
he's such an amazing artist he
inevitably in a certain point will take
the pain out and start drawing the
scenes for you so you get to see the
movie unfold before your eyes because
the way he draws is the way he will
shoot the scene so not so bad
I mean he went to he went to the Royal
Academy you know he from up north you
know it's him and and I was like this
other northern chap there but everybody
else was like rich and dressed in purple
velvet and stuff like this I'm sure he
was the other guy was sort of earning a
bit of money on the side you know
washing up being much etcetera but one
day Brittany looked over his shoulder
and realized that he needed to he he
really was never going to be the page of
this guy must know Steven hauled me and
that's really what persuaded Ridley that
he had to go and look broaden his case
look somewhere else
hmm um there's only five years between
Crimson Tide and gladiator but the
technology of course around them at that
time really did develop and but well
since about gladiator of course is it
it's fairly traditional traditionally
scored film isn't it with big orchestra
I know there's other elements within it
and of course we must talk about lisa
gerrard as a very important vocal
element in it but it actually it's a
fairly traditional score in that sense
it's traditional it's a bit of a mess I
mean I could again you know like like
Rain Man gladiator the cutting room and
my studio they cut in my studio which
made it really collaborative and very
but very early on we had this
conversation that there was absolutely
no females soul in the movie I remember
Pietra had the pianist Pietro Scalia the
editor he had three CDs studying on his
little desk and he picked the first one
up and he went you know what about Lisa
Gerrard
and Ridley and I just went yes okay you
know sounds like a good idea I found it
it's a it's too long a story to tell you
but that whole opening I mean obviously
that does not exist in a script because
what would be the first thing you would
cut for budget one minute of and it's
not even Russell's hand an extras hand
on on the read oh yeah he's totally
Spaulding he does I can go do you want
me to do worse
do you know like at the end when he dies
and he goes through Elysium skates
Ridley had that image in his head he
knew he had seen the gates to heaven
somewhere and he thought wasn't us can
you see he said the Scouts on to Tuscany
wasn't there he thought it was in Spain
wasn't in Spain he thought might have
been because we've shot a lot of it down
and Farnam you know just by Guildford
yeah hey fellow self and then finally he
remembered it's the crew toilet in Malta
all right so the gates to heaven today
today now ruin this for you for good
totally okay good I did know about the
battle say I always think of that when
you're going down that big a road out of
Surrey right just to the right but I
think is where the whole of the battle
scene was done no and you know that like
that I got really big guy who holds up
the head and he's shouting something I
could and Ridley says he's he's the
German what is he saying
and finally buddy said well he's a
Scottish actor and then I understood it
he's going to buy a Honda but with a
Scottish actor I'm the scene that I
picked his is near the end it's the
climax I suppose really of the film in
in the Commodores play by work in
Phoenix finally gets to back
Maximus played by Russell Crowe in the
arena to the death of course battle
that's kind of been brewing from the
very beginning really of the film so
that's the scene but it builds and
there's another one of those scenes
actually we have a few of them tonight
that that builds start small and I like
a good path Acharya oh yes so let's have
a look at the scene then well then we'll
discuss it I knew a man who once said
death smiles at as well all a man can do
is smile back
it's your friend Smarties own death you
must know
he was your father
you loved my father I know but so did I
that makes us brothers doesn't it
smile for me now
step on his armor conceal the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that's a real hair on the back of the
neck moment for me that one and I that
must also be a product of what you were
talking about being in the same or next
door to the editor that all of that
works musically everything works exactly
right musically and the cuts come with
with the music so is that how it worked
we'd like for example with a big landing
on the bass note where we see that that
wider short of there of all of those
amazing shields
I mean it was very much hand in hand you
know it's a the hardest thing was I had
written as crazy you know the battle
stuff and that was incredibly complex
and every time that cut changed Pietro
very kindly cut infobar chunks so I
could let go and figure out but that's
how we're supposed to be doing this
stuff together yeah you know it's
supposed to be collaborative but there's
gonna be lots of people here don't have
that experience at all but-but-but-but
the only thing that stops you from
having experience is well in this case
make sure you have some decent red wine
around now you just just invite invite
your collaborators in you know and they
invite you in I mean I think one of the
advantages I have is that I don't have a
formal musical education so I'm never
going to fall prey to using words that
are incomprehensible to a director like
Allegro or you know you know pizza Chris
Nolan always like major thing on each
movie learning a new musical term that
he could casually drop in ceccato
so no but I mean it it's it's but it's
story we're talking about the story how
are we gonna tell the story plus I mean
look I haven't listened to this since we
did it you know I'm good
the German accent it's really strong
sorry can't help it but just like oh
great
just like with the gems aren't in it
don't just like you you did it after
Crimson Tide where you saw set a style
that everybody then wanted to recreate
the exactly same thing happened here
with Gauri Oh didn't particularly with
the use of research or our voice because
suddenly there were yup I want of a
phrase wailing women over every room I
know they were just wailing women know
that Lisa to rob is singular you know
and I think it's really important to
point out that it wasn't just any waving
woman it was not in this one no and
there are lots of images you know there
were the lesser wailing women no no it
was fantastic because because the I mean
the way we worked was they were
literally in my room couch behind me
Ridley sitting there smoking big cigars
me going he's ruining her voice Lisa
with a microphone the picture up and we
just we just try things up against the
picture and I remember the scene you
know where Russell comes from when
France and his wife has been killed and
we had thought we've done something
extraordinary and we play it so it's
turned into this whole conversation like
a two o'clock in the morning after she
was poisoned by more cigar smoke than he
could imagine
Lisa Wed okay fine I'm gonna have one
more go and you know it's just pretty
wound up at that point and I we just
took the scene up you know meet Lisa
playing to it you know and and she just
laid into it you know and it was a most
amazing performance I mean it came from
it came from a place that you know it's
just an extraordinary place but I'm not
sure you want to go and know where that
place is
I was like it was so dark yeah and I
turn around and it's just like okay
how's that he's good but that's what you
want to do yeah that's that's the job
you want to pin your director in seq
it's not our job as composers isn't to
do what they tell you to do our job is
to Surprise them ourself job is to do
the stuff they can't imagine you know
that's you know if you work with great
directors they love that you know never
thought about it that way that's the
best compliment you can get but one of
the reasons I bring up about this
influence about setting something up and
then everybody wants to imitate it is
that you get you often get the blame for
a lot of things that happen in starting
it and then going bad news on the else
and meanwhile everybody else is trying
to do that one thing but how you you
know this big you know that people do
often blame you for a lot of these
stylistic things and also because you
have such influence over the industry
what do you feel about that what do you
feel about you you're making a face but
you know but but what do you feel about
that when people say oh it's all
handsome is full that we've all got
these big driving strings and then since
going and all that I mean what else can
you you're not by the time everybody's
doing the driving strings I'm doing thin
red light and then everybody's doing
plain red light I mean I I once in one
week I saw six different movies tent
with thin red line one wasn't urban
crime thing one was an animated comedy I
can't know what the other ones were but
the same piece you know I just wrote
what I felt you know and what I felt
like
and what I felt like writing you know I
mean seriously so I'm not trying to set
any trends nor am I trying to ruin music
or the film business or anything
actually no film and business
be separated you know it's like Tobias
one said to me in the words music and
supervision should never be uttered in
the same breath you know I think he has
a point
no but it's it's it's I don't know it's
just I go and do something and by the
time everybody else does it I mean Chris
know that a perfect example is you know
when we did Batman Begins James in how I
had when we did Batman Begins with Chris
we never we never thought we're going to
do another Batman movie I mean I spent
forever getting rid of notes so it would
just be this two note motif you know a
second you have no idea how hard it just
don't need to do the second or third
movie if you since I didn't you know
because I limited my material or my
identity to serve to such a small thing
and then everybody else was sort of
whatever you want to call it in being
influenced by you know a complete lack
of you know I mean like the tiny
fragment of minimalist
nonsense I was of doing so by the time
we cup to the second movie when the
audience doesn't care if it sounds like
me or everybody else has been sort of
slightly borrowing from this very simple
idea suddenly we were sounding old you
know so by the time we got to
interstellar we actually sat down and we
made this stuff what have we done and
what happened to be done you know and
that's probably how the chart or
thinking about well we'll talk about
that we'll get a little bit ahead of
ourselves let's let's stop before
instead of come to Inception oh yeah
yeah I would so my fault that everything
up
it absolutely is your fault no I'm glad
I'm glad you brought that up well well
no no here is a very important
distinction to be made in the script and
I'm not blaming Chris I'm saying
something different
it's a story point as opposed to just a
convenient way in a trailer to do a non
sequitur and yeah it's a really
impressive song I mean it it's written
anything in weird air studios with a
bunch of bass players and a piano with a
brick on the pedal and that's that you
know when you say a bunch of brass
players normally that for you means 18 -
no you do you used a lot how many brass
players you use on inception I have no
idea I know the answer it was a lot it
was a lot right most of them in fact
yeah in London we had quite a few yeah
but but there was you know I mean that
there was an idea that absolutely was no
idea I mean everything story comes first
story comes inception look inception is
inception this is how inception start
Chris wrote me up going hey you want to
take the kids to Beach so a person
sitting on the beach watching our kids
and he's going got this idea for this
movie and I realized that he's telling
me the idea that this might be
intellectually somewhat tricky for an
audience to follow and so so I you know
and maybe maybe he was a little worried
about that - yeah so I just tried to
write a piece I tried to write music but
in a funny way was reassuring to the
audience that even if you didn't get it
the music was like a river and you were
on this little boat and sometimes it
gets a bit bumpy and sometimes it gets a
bit boring or whatever it does but you
are on a journey ain't gonna get to the
end of the journey and all I promise you
it's all gonna be all right you know or
whatever you know
have an experience you know the I be
dead
we could spend the rest of the night
discussing the story of Inception I
don't think there's even worth as
they're tempting too much but one thing
we should say ahead of the of the clip
and I'm sure everyone knows this who's
seen it but they one of the key songs or
the key song in the film is the Edith
Piaf which we knew which nearly didn't I
mean a few you know this this is where
it's sort of once he cast smile Katya
who had played EDPs you know we then
questioned ourselves what people think
we were being self self reverential or
you know whatever and then the next
thing that happened was that Warner's
quite rightly said to shoot in Paris is
very expensive
Kanye should be scenes in England I
remember saying to Chris as soon as you
say there were at Paris you do one shot
of Paris it's actually a great way of
saving money because everybody will know
that somewhere in there is some great
tragic love story and yes all you have
to do is you have to have one shot in
Paris and it'll serve story forever so
yes it did the song really didn't happen
and that's right in the beginning of the
intro there's a trombones do a Papa and
in the script it was you know that to
show time stretched out that that those
two trombone notes would become I mean
he's tricky in the world you know it's
like slow it down and someone discovered
it and put it on YouTube and said I've
discovered what handsomer does in this
and it's like massively slowed down the
introduction of it appear and your
response was I can't believe it took
them so long
I know because because we were trying to
make a story point and if we had failed
because you didn't nobody got it on her
on YouTube okay but this
clip again there's no real point
explaining it because it's too
complicated and those that I've seen
inception will know but the reason I've
chosen this obviously is it's a very
dramatic section but also it contains
the elements of that slowed down as you
know a very hard part but also idea what
you pay and also the Blom you have
already mentioned so let's have a look
at this clip
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fine
and as is traditional with anything
connected with you I think we've just
blown the sub-woofer good that is the
the music all the way through is it's
extraordinary is so original in the way
then in which it's used and I think
there's a much participant doc just to
you but also the way in which you work
with Chris Nolan but it was written
parallel to the movie it wasn't actually
written to the movie was written about
Christmas shooting and then they came
the point of course where he finished
shooting and I said okay kind of the
movie now it's to do you know write your
name pretty well just finish the score
first and then book and then we did a
second part sort of adjusting things but
most of it was written just just really
just from that discussion we had on the
beach or seeing fragments of watching
you know looking at design and I just
took freedom that completely I mean I
mean you know like I heard this not the
brand you know forget that up but I
heard this other side my head's like for
three days I was trying to figure out
what it was and finally I figured out
what it was it was Johnny Marr it's not
an electric guitar right it's Johnny
Marr because you need to have the person
playing at you you are so I remember
phoning Chris and I said you have to
listen to this whole paragraph before
you say no the worst thing in film music
electric guitars and orchestra it's
absolutely awful but if I said what
about Orchestra and Johnny Marr what
would you say he said give him a ring
you know so that's how that came about
because I I heard Johnny's sound and I
couldn't it took me about it
yeah oh that's what that is yeah yeah
well there and he's just one of the many
collaborators you work with oh yeah you
know it's not just not just talking
about directors here a lot of musical
collaborators that you love working with
yeah no because because because it's
you know look the thing I've learned
over the years is that there's a
shorthand for composers and musicians
where we go the strings the brass etc
and it's not that it's individuals that
make up that string section and you do
want to go and pick your individual
players because they bring you know they
bring something to the pieman they
literally bring something to the party
you're very loyal aren't you - I mean so
many of the musicians that work with you
in the studio particularly in our
studios they're the same musicians that
work with you for years and years and
years yes I mean actually we have we had
a problem huge from we had booked our
sessions to air and we couldn't go
because remember when the volcano blew
up in Iceland oh yeah all right
so we'd booked these sessions and we
could have gotten there but I said to
Chris what if the world came up rose
again we can't get back so we had rigged
up this whole thing
loads of cameras at air and loads of
microphones and actually I could hit the
top back button in my studio la and talk
to them but we really quickly noticed
that if we had no nice new systems it
wouldn't have worked because you you
hear the sound of Mary Scully saying
something you know it's married asking
the question you have bass you know yeah
and and they they are our collaborators
they're our family I mean you know
they're it's it's why are we loyal to
them because they've been loyal to us I
mean they give you know we've put them
through some stuff difficult times
trust me Dunkirk is not for the favor
okay um the next clip I've put in
because it's huge fun and I remember
when I first saw it which actually was
at the premiere and I thought is one of
the most outrageous I mean even by your
standards completely outrageous section
and this is in Sherlock Holmes a game of
shadows when Sherlock Holmes played by
Oh Robert Downey jr. and Watson Jude Law
and they go to the
opera because they're trying to find a
bomb which as it turns out isn't in
there just to give it away a little bit
but playing in the Opera House is Don
Giovanni
but it's Don Giovanni by Mozart as
scored by handsomer and this is a scene
when you are having a lot of fun in this
scene so I thought I've thrown in
because it is a lot of fun let's talk
about let's watch it and then we'll talk
about outfits sorry
[Laughter]
[Music]
I was mistaken
what I met mistake
[Music]
Boutique please new TVC
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you don't know Don Giovanni it
doesn't normally sound like bags oh it's
it's thrilling stuff I mean must be fun
working really on stuff like that
there's a lot of Schubert as well in
there I need it you know I told you
earlier about that little problem well
on the first Sherlock movie how they
didn't like the music well it's because
I had all these Roma or gypsy violins
going on and the crib nearly got me
fired guy loved it you know but it
nearly got me fired and it was really
funny opening the script for the second
one is the second one and the first page
is the gypsy camp I don't
oh come on guys it's like success is the
best revenge
[Laughter]
yeah
you can't show this will be in Germany
without getting beheaded you know you
know you're like you're doing serious
damage certain work I am doing sure I I
grew up with you actually if I think
about it I went to my first Mozart opera
bonus to now half years old and it
sounded that big so this was just making
it the way I remembered it as a kid it's
huge and amazing and bombastic and those
diminished chords are fantastic oh you
know okay actually sells a lot these
days
all right we're going to end with a main
clip with interstellar so we're back
with Christopher Nolan again now this
again is an opportunity given to you by
Chris to be creative away from the film
itself wasn't it this famous body plays
you all know the story do I have to turn
it again who doesn't know the story
everybody knows good all right
it's that right well he he gave you a
concept rather than anything about a
relationship you have to press your
buttons didn't
to get them get their creative juices no
yeah it's the the movie is about the
relationship between a father and his
daughter and Chris had written something
from me typewritten and turning
afterwards that I looked you know he
very carefully whited of the AH and her
son became he so he was writing about my
relationship with my son Jake we knows
very well just be being you know if you
wanna go to the beach and discuss its
inception so yes and we inevitably I
think anything and everything I've ever
written the only place I know how to
come from this it has to be
extraordinary personal because I have no
technique and I have no formal education
so the only thing I know how to write
about something that is inside me and
Chris knows this and he is crafty and
taps right into that you know and and
and yes I mean I've I've never shown
anybody the letter and I will never show
anybody let the letter because it's
extraordinarily candid and personal and
I think extraordinary true to my
relationship with myself it's the sound
world of interstellar which I find so
striking the combination of instruments
and particularly of course the use of
the church organ so how did that come
about what why was that such an
important self I mean the trivial arms
but it is a trivial art yes because of
the way the stuff we had done in Batman
our inception had sort of traveled into
it somehow into other movies we sat down
and we went you know what haven't we
done and Chris has one Prentiss said hi
Paul
and as soon as he said it and I grew up
it's a long story that I grew up in in a
house that just around the corner there
was a house that had a pie box I grew up
as a kid any more of those things but I
just remember the shape which is you
know that those big olden pipes are just
like Rockets themselves and I thought it
was
incredibly appropriate admired my only
fear was you know oh god it's gonna
sound like a bad hammer house of horror
did you in a second that that's the
connotation you have to pipe off and I
thought but but that'll be an
interesting challenge
you know let's see if we can't go and
sort of increase the vocabulary a little
bit and did you write all my Suites of
music which could then be fashioned into
the had all again it was all written it
was all written away from the picture
and then we crafted to fit the picture I
mean that the Chris doesn't cut film to
music we it ourselves a really good
example of there was there were swamps
he was shooting in Iceland and he was
phoning me here in London he's going I
want to try I mean they just give you a
set of seams and I just want you to see
if he can write something and it was
very complicated and had to hit this
cabin and hit this and I'm doing Chris I
don't think I can do this I think I need
the footage and he goes well just give
it a go I mean let's see how we do
because in the past our sense of how
long a scene is or how long a shot
should be held has always been really
the same so I broke this super
complicated it goes from here to there
and send it over to Iceland and Furnham
and so how was it it hits everything you
know we're still in sync you know
because you don't want to be you don't
want to be tied to the mechanics of
things you don't you don't want your
imagination to be tied down by the
mechanics of things either but you know
good film editors and actually who's our
editor on all of crisis movies I first
worked with him on a Peter Weir film
where he was the sound editor so he
comes from sound and and and the editors
I worked with really well either like
Joe Walker you know
twelve years a slave and I just I'm just
been working with on widows for Steve
McQueen um he actually cut he's actually
he started out as a film composer so
it's not just that we discuss music but
there's a you know he has a rhythm he
has it and it's more than a rhythm that
is that there's a there's a musical form
of editing you know we feel the story is
with him the scene we're going to see
from interstellar is a key scene you say
the nub of the movie is this
relationship between the father and
daughter that this is probably the most
powerful scene in that at least in the
early early part of the film where
Cooper played by Matthew McConaughey is
saying goodbye to his daughter Merv and
his family before he goes off into space
to hopefully save humanity I mean the
this whole see this whole piece of music
was just written as a piece of music and
actually Chris and I are self working
I'm highly sure what it can do and Lee
the editor just chuck it laid it in and
it just did everything it was supposed
to do I never got changed it never got
touched the cotton elegant touch it's a
long clip but I think it's important
that we see it from beginning to end
because of how it builds and builds and
builds it's nicely constructed so
actually it doesn't have an ending which
you know that's why I stopped writing
you know just tough the ending is just
abandoned
you have to talk to me a mouth
I need to fix this before I go well keep
it broken see you after state however
after you kids came along your mom she
said something to me I never quite
understood she said now we're just here
to be memories were kids
how do you know there's no what you
meant
what's your opinion you're the ghost of
your children's future
you think ghosts exist
that's right
for me
I can't be here girls right now
and he exists
they chose me Murph they chose me you
saw you're the one even letting me do
that's exactly why you can't go
I figured out the message homeward you
know what it is
stay it says stay dad he'll believe me
look at the books look at this it says
date why you're not listening it says
day
one for you one for me when I'm up there
in hypersleep or or Jalan SB light or
near black hole
time's gonna change for me now he's
gonna run more slowly back
we're gonna compare I'll run differently
for us yeah
maybe by the time I get back meal we
might even be the same age you and me
what imagine
have nitro in your career path
Nordia
but don't dumb I don't make me leave
like this come on Murph don't make me
leave like this Murph
I love you forever
yeah me I love you forever and I'm
coming back
I'm coming back
how'd it go I'm fine it's fine
[Music]
trouble safe here you look after our
place oh my
hey can I use your truck Larry God maybe
your child
I'll make sure they bring it back
but that's my kids out
[Music]
[Music]
start
[Music]
to ignition and
ages look beginning roll program when
when we did that film live here in this
hall I think that scene is one of the
loudest things that's ever happened in
that room and that includes Led Zeppelin
in 1970 it was absolutely story and
actually people who were there it wasn't
kind of almost semi religious experience
for people there was something about
that that film and also the music that
it really did connect well it's sort of
rare that you actually get to use the
that immaculate pipe augmentis how it
was actually Roger sayers was the
organist at Temple Church and played all
this whoo
I remember him coming up to curse me he
was that that whole thing you know it's
a typical similar stupidities like it's
the lowest note on the middle very
effective um and on the subject of the
of the live performance this before I
open the floor for questions live
performance has become a very important
part of your life more recently in the
last few years with your tour around
around the world there's also the world
of hands immer which is an orchestral
concert which is now doing the rounds
and of course their live performances of
gladiator and and interstellar that
that's an extraordinary thing that it's
exploded and you've become even though
you always deny it a bit of a rock star
when it comes to being on the stage with
your shows why did you decide to do that
in the first place and how do you what
do you make of it all now I had all
these mates and they're famous and they
shall not drop their names right now but
they they saw sat me down and went you
know there comes a moment in time that
comes a point where you have to look
your audience in the eye you can't hide
behind the screen forever and we don't
give a [ __ ] about your stage fright and
all this stuff and actually I do have to
drop one name and then I was sort of you
know they started to talk me into it and
we're still growing
now I don't want to do this I'm
terrified yeah you know whatever the
excuse right Pharrell Williams was one
of the people ganging up on me I
remember getting up and he's walking
towards the door and he just turns
around he goes hey I'm playing but
Grammys do you know play guitar the
Grammys for me I was going only an idiot
would say no do you mean it's like wow
okay so and it was great because it
wasn't me you know I nobody gave a [ __ ]
about me it was about Pharrell but he
kept eye contact with me throughout the
whole performance just to make sure I'm
all right and I realized it was it was
delicious it was great fun and it was
another and I should just you know a
story master just get over yourself
[Laughter]
because it seemed it seemed a Massa you
know I mean I literally did you know
Howie goldsmith promoted who have known
forever and you know I said to Harvey
Chivo what do you think anybody will
come alright
yeah he was right because because I had
this I have you know I had this idea
which was no images from the films and
no conductor because III wanted those
musicians that I've been making music
with forever I wanted them to have I
wanted to take the ball away that it
could conduct inevitably create and I
wanted them to have the Meccan economist
relationship was the audience you know I
wanted them to be look in at into their
eyes as well and I want to I wanted to
show off all those amazing people that
have been
working on these scores and you know no
but no anywhere they look like and I
just I just wanted to celebrate them in
a way before we see the last clip what's
the last thing well we'll come to it Oh
what do you it it it's connected with
this last question which is what are you
working on right now I can lie to you
and say I've just finished with uh Steve
McClean that fun where you want to hear
no I'm working on a new version of The
Lion King the live-action the
live-action version you don't know I've
decided I don't turn on sets of
correctly you know sometimes itself goes
and it attaches to your question in a
funny way you know sometimes the best
things happen for all the wrong reasons
I didn't want to do the like I didn't
want to do a fuzzy animal movie but my
my daughter at the time sir we were six
years old and I couldn't ever take her
to premiere of her oh let's go and see a
Tony Scott movie with lots of you know
let's go and see true romance with
everything blowing up so I thought oh
I'll do this so I can show off as a dad
and take my daughter to the premiere and
then I'm working on this thing and I'm
you know I think it's gonna just be a
laugh it's gonna be easy and then
suddenly comes to think that in the
middle of the movie the dad dies and my
father died when I was very young and
whatever you whatever anybody tells you
there's no way children can actually
cope with that I mean they they're all
they do is they they suppress it and
they you know
and suddenly I found myself in front of
a cartoon with fuzzy animals having to
confront this this you know thing so
yeah I mean it it became rather of an
important part of growing up I suppose I
grew up more than my daughter
well the clip is from The Lion King and
we we've chosen this because you may
notice that quite a lot of clips tonight
have been quite intense actually and
this is got a nice big uplifting
building so you'll go away with a smile
on faces this is a famous scene where a
Simba sees his father in the water in a
vision and his father has something to
send him off with and so here it is and
it's the lion king oscar winning score
[Music]
that's not my father it's just my
reflection you all
[Music]
you see he lives in you
[Music]
father
[Music]
Simba you have forgotten me no how could
I you have forgotten who you are so
forgotten me look inside yourself Simba
you are that what you have become you
must take your place in the circle of
life how can I go back I'm not I used to
be you are my son
[Music]
no please don't leave me
father
[Music]
[Music]
what was that the weather data peculiar
don't you think yeah looks like the
winds are changing ah
change is good yeah but it's not easy I
know what I have to do but going back
means I'll have to face my past I've
been running from it for so long
ow Jesus what was that for
it doesn't matter each in the past yeah
yeah but it still hurts
oh yes the past can hurt but the way I
see it you can either run from it or
learn from it
ah you see so what are you going to do
first I'm gonna take your stick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you ladies and gentlemen thank you
all very much for coming but hands you
are what's the score
I did oh my god that's pretty
oh my goodness gracious hands everyone
in here knows that you you know you're
the busiest film composer on the planet
we really really appreciate you giving
our lovely time here thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]